hi i'm chalotav hasa a second year
computational neuroscience phd student
at the donders institute and today i
want to talk to you a little bit about
learning math by yourself for
computational neuroscience so based on
my previous video on how to learn
computational neuroscience by yourself a
self-study guide i decided to make a
follow-up videos for this series because
i decided that i think i didn't go into
depth enough on some of the subjects and
mathematics being one of them a lot of
you have asked for more resources on how
to really learn mathematics by yourself
so today i will dive into the top three
topics that i think you need to learn
which is linear algebra calculus and
statistics and probability theory those
two combined and i think if you learn
these three topics you will really be
set on your conversational neuroscience
journey and go through it quite smoothly
at least in the mathematics part i also
want to ask you if you have any question
on how to learn computational
neuroscience by yourself please put it
in the comments below because i do look
at it and i will decide if i will make
another video on how to learn
computational neuroscience more smoothly
so put all your questions and queries
down in the comments below and let's
begin so the first thing i would do is
kind of to get an introduction into math
is to follow the course introduction to
mathematical thinking on coursera i
really like the idea of this course
because i think that math is not only
something you learn but it's also a way
of thinking so it's a way of reasoning
that's quite different from how we
reason in daily life normally and i
think following this course you will get
kind of an introduction in how to really
get a grasp of mathematical thinking so
i will recommend a lot of courses from
mit and that's because i really like the
course setup of mit you can get the
lectures but you can also get the
lecture notes and you can look at the
videos and also there are a lot of extra
reading materials for example so the
books are also placed on there and i
think that just gives you a lot of
material to work with another thing i
really like from the mit courses is that
they put their exams online so once you
feel comfortable with the topic you can
try to take the exam and that will
really tell you if you learned the topic
well and i think for mathematics this is
super important because sometimes we
think that we know the math well but we
actually only understand a small part of
the theory and cannot really apply it so
for linear algebra there are a few
things you need to know that's vector
spaces linear transformation matrices
and their operations eigenvalues and
eigenvectors and this is just among
others so the first course i would take
is 18.06
which is the linear algebra course on
the mit website i will also put all the
resources down below so you can just
look it up and with that i would read
the book by gilbert strang on linear
algebra and its application and i think
if you follow this course really in
depth that you will already have a
really good grasp on linear algebra i
would also recommend the series essence
on linear ultra bar by three blue and
one brown i think they explain it in a
really nice well-rounded manner that's
not too hard to understand and lastly if
you don't really like the mit course
setup i also like the course from khan
academy on linear algebra i kind of like
how ken academy sets up their courses
with a lot of practice materials so i
think that's also a good option so what
you might use it for in computational
neuroscience is mostly like pca ica is
applied a lot and just in general linear
algebra and working with matrices is
used a lot for computational
neuroscience because all the data we get
is in this matrix format so you have to
be able to manipulate matrices and
multiply them with each other know the
inner product the outer product these
kind of things are just really important
so the next skill i want to dive into is
probability and statistics and i
combined these two because they're
pretty similar in their reasoning in
mathematics for statistics they're
different type of skills that you need
so one of them is just summary
statistics so you need to know things
like the mean the mode the median if
you've done a bachelor in a science
subject you will know these things and
also aside from summary statistics it's
also good if you do experiments to know
experimental statistics so how to do a
t-test a z-test and f-test all these
words that you may have heard before and
also in general just to know how to
calculate p-values for example and how
to do a bonferroni correction these are
topics you kind of will have to dive
into and then for probability theory
it's good to know general probabilistic
measures to know the base theorem for
example chain rule among others so the
courses that i would recommend are again
one from mit that's
18.05 which is called probability and
statistics there's also a course on cam
academy again if you don't like the mit
courses on statistics and probability
then i also really like this website
it's called seeing theory and i love the
kind of visualizations they made for
example you can click on chance events
and then you can really play around with
the different probability theories they
show i love this website for a more
intuitive grasp on probability theory
and i also personally really like this
think stats book which if you know how
to program is a really nice way to learn
statistics through programming so if
you're more a programmer i would go that
route maybe if you like that kind of
information as well then the next skill
you need is calculus so calculus is
quite wide for calculus there's
derivative gradients integration but
also multivariate calculus to take it a
step further i again really like the
book from gilbert strang for this which
is called calculus
it i think that's a really good way to
learn it on mit there are also different
courses so there's 18.01 and 18.02 so
these courses are about calculus and
multivariate calculus so i think they
really go into depth in these two topics
quite well there's also 18.03 which is a
little bit more about differential
equations so what you might use calculus
for is just everything i think like
derivatives optimization techniques all
kind of programming algorithms are based
on calculus in their essence so so to
get a good feeling of calculus and to
really grasp how to implement it is
quite important i think okay so now i
want to talk a little bit more about how
i would learn mathematics if i would go
about learning it by myself because
learning mathematics by yourself is a
really challenging undertaking
especially if you're not used to
mathematical thinking one of the first
resources i want to give you is this mit
challenge by scott young so scott young
is someone that really inspired me he
learned a computer science major by
himself in 12 months whereas normally it
would take four years and he did this
all by self learning and he recorded his
self-learning journey in its entirety on
his blog so if you're going on a
self-learning journey i would follow his
blog and see how he went about it he
really explains how he learned the
material and then takes or took the
exams that helped him to learn all of
this material so i think that's a really
inspiring resource but i also want to
give you seven tips to learn mathematics
by yourself if you're planning to do it
so the first thing is to know what
you're learning math for i think if
you're on this video you kind of know
you're learning it for computational
neuroscience but in general it's good to
have this goal really clear because
there will be points in your learning
journey that you will falter or will
kind of fall off the wagon because
learning mathematics is hard so it's
good to know what you're doing it for
such that you can always have this in
your back of your mind when times get
rough the second thing is practice is
key especially with mathematics practice
is really important you can understand
the theory sometimes but if you cannot
implement it you will still not pass
your exam on mathematics so what i did
when i was learning theoretical physics
for my bachelor's we had to learn a lot
of mathematics and i just worked every
day for two hours in the morning on
mathematics and
doing this really challenged my brain
and really allowed me to get into this
mathematics mindset and i would only do
practice questions so i wouldn't look at
any theory i wouldn't read anything i
would just do the practice questions and
if i pass them go to the next practice
question and try to finish as many of
them in two hours and i think doing this
will really challenge you mathematically
and will really speed up your learning
process number three for me is to work
on new and old problems so something
that i learned when i was learning
mathematics is that it's sometimes easy
when you finish a problem to just skip
over it without really going into depth
as to how you finished it i think a good
way is to try to solve a problem three
times at least because sometimes if you
solve it one time you don't fully
understand it or you're not fast enough
because in mathematics you also have to
be quite fast at solving the problems so
what i would do is i would put three
circles next to a problem and if i
solved it for example in the first week
one time then i would try to solve it
again a month later and again two months
later then i really knew that i know the
steps that had to be taken to solve the
different mathematical problems so solve
new and old problems then the fourth
thing is to memorize key concepts i know
everyone in mathematics and also physics
always tells you to not memorize and
just understand everything but i think
at a certain point you will come in your
mathematics journey that is just too
much to keep everything in your mind
because you can derive everything from
scratch but this will just take too long
so i think if you have this graph of
mathematics i think it's good to learn
all the central
notes by heart such that you can just
move to the graph a little bit quicker
because if you every time have to derive
the central notes from scratch that will
just take up too much space so it's kind
of good to have these central notes
always in the front of your mind so the
fifth thing i would go to is to
understand your mistakes i think when we
make a mistake in mathematics it's
sometimes easy to look at the solutions
then solve it again and just think you
learned it but sometimes it's nice to
really understand why you made a certain
mistake because it doesn't always have
to be a mistake because the way you
solve mathematical problems sometimes
they have different solutions so it's
good to really understand why you took a
certain journey or why you weren't able
to solve something for example then the
sixth thing is consistency we kind of
talked about this a little bit before
but just be consistent with your journey
i think doing 10 minutes every day is
better than to spend an hour in the
weekends for example so consistency is
one of the most important things for
your mathematics journey and then the
seventh thing and this is really when
you know you've become a mathematician
in some sense is if you apply the
mathematics outside so i remember quite
clearly that when i was learning
different engineering techniques that i
was riding my bike at a certain point
and i was thinking about like rotational
speed and torque and these kind of
concepts whilst riding my bike and i
think as you learn mathematics better
it's nice to think about the concepts
when you're outside as well such as you
can just kind of challenge your
mathematical mind and this will really
sharpen you
outside of your true learning time as
well so these were all my resources and
tips and tricks for learning mathematics
for computational neuroscience if you
have any tips for me or any resources
that you really love please put them
down in the comments below because i
always give them to students next year
and i learn a lot from you guys as well
and also if you again have any queries
on computational neuroscience i would
also love to read those and try my best
to answer them and otherwise see you
next week bye